keeping them out of school for a day
longer
i want to thank all the teachers who've
got their schools ready and have been
teaching throughout the whole period
whether that's remotely or in person
your work
has been astonishing and i want to thank
the parents and all those who've been
teaching
at home who've had to master zoom who
had to communicate every detail of the
syllabus from fronted adverbials
to quadratic equations and we all know
that the
so the burden has disproportionately
fallen on
on women often holding down jobs and
providing child care
at the same time so our job now as
as government is to build on your
efforts so that from now on
our school children not only catch up on
lost
learning but take the biggest possible
step forwards
with a concerted national program
for educational recovery
it's thanks to all of you parents
teachers
pupils thanks to this huge national
effort to keep kids at home
that we have been able significantly to
reduce the spread of the virus
and so today we've been able to take
that
crucial first step on what we hope is
our
cautious but irreversible road map to
freedom
today allowing people to meet one on one
outside for the first time in months
allowing care home visits
to take place with all appropriate
precautions
and this first step on the road map is
made possible
above all by our nhs which has now
vaccinated more than
one third of the entire uk population
we take this step with confidence
because
all four of the most vulnerable groups
have not only been vaccinated
in overwhelming numbers but it's now
three weeks
since they've or at least three weeks
since they've received their first
dose so that they'll be feeling the full
benefits
of the vaccine protection
we will continue on this roadmap
but we must remember that today's return
to schools will of course have an impact
on the spread of the virus
and so at all times and as we decide
on the next steps forward and when we
take them
we will be driven by the data and with
the number
of patients uh being admitted to
hospital with covid each day
still around eight times higher than the
lows of last summer it's more vital
than ever to follow the rules hands face
space
and please continue to stay at home
protect the nhs
and save lives thank you very much i'm
now going to hand over to jenny to do
the slides
thank you prime minister could i have
the first slide please
um so what we can see here is a is a
pleasing picture but one which i think
still has some caution attached to it
uh um this shows the number of people
testing positive both by pcr
and lfd test for covid19 and the recent
seven-day average you can see is 5889.
now that case rate is still falling it's
below now
100 per hundred thousand in every region
across the country but it's not
uniformly across the country so it's
really important
that we continue to uh practice social
distancing
uh hunt space and space as the prime
minister said and continue to observe
uh all of our hand washing as well
you can see that the rate is back now
about where it was
uh in the end of september so
still quite a high level this is a level
at which a new wave
could easily take off again from and we
need to persist with all of those
actions next slide please
so this slide shows the number of people
in hospital with covert 19 in the uk
that
dotted line across the middle shows what
the first peak was in
uh about 21 000 on the 12th of april
and then the real height that it climbed
to
over the new year again it's back down
to
around 10 000 but this is still a
substantial strain on the nhs
and not one that we can afford to rise
from again with any
further pandemic waves so we still you
can see that there is a lag
as we'd expect in the case numbers and
then that appearing
in our hospital rate so a good sign
but still some way to go next slide
please
and the third slide we have here shows
the number of deaths sadly
of people who had a positive test result
and then died
within 28 days of that first test this
is reported up to the 8th of march and
again
it's really good to be able to see that
the average
rate 7 day rate is now down to 206
deaths we can see those characteristic
reporting blips
at the weekend where the rate's lower
which is why we have that rolling
average
uh and you can see now that again this
is falling right down
the the really good news here is that as
the vaccine starts
to have effect in the older people
who've been vaccinated first and are
most vulnerable
that the the impact on the number of
deaths is starting to come down more
rapidly
than some of the other indicators and
one will slide i think please
and what we have here is a number of
people who've received a vaccination for
covid19 so
huge numbers and extremely fast progress
thanks to colleagues particularly in the
nhs but right around
the country and local authorities and
volunteers the blue
bluey purple line is those who've
received their first dose but if you
look at the bottom of the slide
you can see an orange line starting to
rise up and these are individuals
who've now come to the 12-week period
and have had their second dose as well
so these are each individual counted
we're now heading up to 24 million on
this and i think when we
get a little bit further we'll be
heading right up towards
50 percent of our population so really
good news but while we're understanding
what the effect of vaccine is on
transmission we anticipate this will
have really good
impact on protecting individuals from
serious illness
but we still need to watch and wait to
see what's happening so again
the strong message is uh keep practicing
those social distancing measures
thank you thanks very much jenny let's
go to arjun from watford
young people have been hit very hard as
a result of the panzerback however the
government has seemed to put us at the
bottom of the priority list
what is the government doing to ensure
that young people will be catered for
in terms of support for both now and the
after effects of when the pandemic is
over
arjun thank you very much the most
important thing that we
able to do today is to get young people
back into
uh into school obviously for all those
who are of school age that makes a
a massive difference and i think that
that will
is something that is going to be a
really really welcome
uh to to families up and down uh the
the country uh but the uh for those who
young people who are thinking about jobs
who are thinking about
uh their their futures uh clearly we
want to give you the the maximum
possible help and that's why we have
the kickstart funds uh two billion
pounds
uh to uh help young people specifically
the 18 to 24
year old group arjun into work and to
make sure that we support businesses
now with special packages to enable them
to to take on
young people this is going to be it's
going to continue to be a tough time
uh for for the country but i'm confident
that we'll be able to
to get through it very well and start to
have a a real jobs-led recovery but for
now we've got to
continue to beat the uh the pandemic uh
arjun
that's not in any way to underestimate
the uh
the pressure young people have under
have been under
i do understand how tough it has been
obviously particularly for for
university students who haven't had
anything like the
university experience that uh they would
have liked
but the faster we can uh get through it
uh and uh the more we can observe the
guidances
as jenny has has said working together
we'll be able to continue on
uh the cautious but irreversible road
map and
uh and give young people the the freedom
uh that they need uh let's go to phoebe
from
from leeds i've been hearing a lot about
vaccine passports to allow british
tourists to travel again but i'm just
wondering how this is going to work for
under 16s
i can imagine this is a question on a
lot of people's minds and we're all just
so eager to start booking our holidays
again
phoebe a really excellent question about
vaccine passports and how they work for
under 16s uh we're looking at
the way these types of vaccination
certificates
might work they do raise all sorts of uh
issues uh for those who like
under 16 year olds who uh who might not
uh have
had a vaccination for one reason or
another though those who
aren't medically able to get a
vaccination for instance there are some
some complexities we're looking at what
they're they're thinking of
in other countries and we'll be making
sure we report back to you
uh as soon as we put to everybody as
soon as we possibly can as you know
as you may know uh work is being done by
uh
by by michael gove the chance of the
duchy of lancaster on that on that whole
issue it's a novel one for our country
we've never had uh
this type of question before within the
domestic
uk economy within our own uh home market
though clearly
vaccine passports as an idea uh are not
new
when it comes to international travel
there have been certificates for things
like
uh yellow fever and and other diseases
in the past and i'm sure
that that will be a feature of our life
in the future
uh uh ben wright of the bbc
uh thank you a question to both of you
first
now that schools in england have
reopened do you accept that infection
rate levels will go up
and what would be an acceptable level
and a second question to the prime
minister please
in their interview harry and megan claim
the royal family
failed to look after their mental health
and that an unnamed member of the family
asked how
dark their son archie's skin might be
what did you think when you heard those
comments and should buckingham palace
investigate the allegations
ben thank you very much uh look on your
on your second
question perhaps the best thing i can
say is that i've always had the
highest admiration for the queen
and the unifying role that she plays in
our country and
across the commonwealth and as for uh
the rest of all other matters to do with
the royal family
i've spent a long time now not
commenting on royal family matters and i
don't intend
to depart from that today and on your
quest your question about you know the
the
budget of risk involved in opening up
schools which i
actually referred to earlier on we do
accept i think
jenny that of course there will be a
risk of increased uh transmission that's
inevitable
uh if you open up uh schools for
millions of kids across the
uh the country that is going to uh to
happen
but we think that we can do it now in
the way that we are
because we have the proportion of the
population vaccinated that i
that i described the groups one to four
and are having had the
uh the immunity uh bedded in uh after at
least
three weeks and we think it is it is
prudent uh to be able to
do so but as i said to uh earlier on
uh we will continue to be driven uh by
uh
data and not dates and uh as we approach
uh the next steps april the 12th may the
17th uh june the 21st we'll
we will continue to assess where we've
where we've got to
the data on the vaccinations and the the
impact that they're having is
is very encouraging but we have to
remain very very cautious
um well exactly as the prime minister
said we do expect there to be an impact
on our and i think
um people will probably have have seen
some of the sage comments on that but
clearly education is of critical public
health importance
just as much as uh covid is um and so
what we do know is or at least we can't
disentangle
the social interaction element uh of
that rise in our so it's just as likely
it's people meeting
at school gates or the different numbers
of social interactions as much as it is
in school so i think the critical point
is
there are new interventions so the
testing for schools
is in place starting from now and
gradually for
for some senior pupils going forward
what that's likely to do
is diminish the number of uh community
transmission cases
which could come into school so schools
will be inherently safer places but
equally
it will reach back into families so
although i suspect we may see
a rise at the start with luck as we go
forward and people get used to using
that testing
whole families will be protected as well
and the whole issue about vaccination of
course is we have now protected
the most vulnerable individuals as we
come down the age groups and into those
with underlying
health conditions and so the impact on
our hospitals going forward is likely to
be significantly less
thank you uh robert person idb uh good
afternoon prime minister jenny harris
um prime minister is this the moment to
spend two hundred thousand pounds on the
refurbishment of your downing street
flat and
have any of the bills been settled by
the conservative party or private donors
and with the vaccination program being
significantly accelerated since you
prepared your road to
releasing the lockdown measures won't
you consider
speeding up the release of lockdown
measures
well thank you very much uh robert and
uh
on your on your first point all i can
say is all such
inquiries will be uh answered with the
normal declarations in the in the normal
way
and on your on your second question
about accelerating the
um the timetable and the and the
the road map people have asked us to do
this
uh many times and and uh of course
i understand the the urgency that people
feel
but we have to be driven by the data we
we have to look at the the rates of
infection uh don't forget they're still
very high by the standards of of last
year
we still have thousands of people in
hospital uh with kobed and
we've seen uh alas in other european
countries
that the curve is is going up again and
we remember frankly what happened
uh every time we've seen those upward
curves in
uh in our friends and neighbors that
it's not too long
after that that we see an increase in
this country
as well and so we just got to remain uh
prudent
and the whole point about this uh road
map robert is it's intended to be
cautious but
irreversible and we think we can do that
because of the success of the
of the vaccine rollout that you uh that
you rightly describe
but i think people would really rather
trade um
some uh submergency and some some haste
in favor of a security uncertainty about
the those dates that we've
uh that we've set out april the 12th may
the 17th uh june the 21st and
uh and so on thanks robert
uh ben kentish of lbc thank you prime
minister two questions for you if i may
firstly a couple of weeks ago on the
issue of financial support
for people who are having to
self-isolate you said we'd hear more
from the chancellor last week
we didn't hear any more on that it's
something that your scientific advisors
have called for repeatedly the head of
test and trace has said uh
suggested is necessary will we he hear
more on that issue or do you think those
advisors
are wrong on that and secondly if i
could just follow up on on robert's
question
you said that the roadmap would be
guided by the data at the moment it's
guided by data that is
overly pessimistic we know the vaccine
rollout has been better vaccines are
more effective the number of people in
hospital is at the lower end of what was
predicted in those models
if it is truly guided by data will it be
uh assessed at regular intervals to make
sure
that we're not prolonging the resumption
of normality and the economic damage
that goes with that the longer than the
science says is necessary thank you
yeah thanks so much ben the uh
what what we're doing in addition to
help people to to solve isolate in
addition to the
uh the um the 500 pounds support and
and all the rest of it is giving money
particularly to councils
uh i have a figure of 170 million pounds
more
in my head to support them uh to to help
them
uh give uh people who who who really
need it to
uh to self-isolate and that's that's one
of the that's that's
possibly what i was referring to last
time that we
uh that we talked and on uh
your your question about um being driven
by the
uh by the data and and the data now
being positive
um i look i i accept that and i i agree
that there are some encouraging signs
but
the whole point is um you know we
remember where we were uh last summer we
had the
disease down uh to levels much below
where it is
today and then we saw what happened uh
with the
uh with the spike and uh
i i think it's fantastic that the
vaccine rollout is proving
so successful but don't forget that
there is
a big budget of risk involved in opening
schools
uh today in the way that uh that we are
that's that's just
inevitable you heard what jenny had to
say about the effect on the art
we think it's we think it's manageable
we think it's right we think we're
prudent
uh to be doing what we are as i say i
think the the biggest risk is
is not opening schools now but we'll
continue
uh to take a cautious and prudent
approach because i think that is
really what uh what i think business uh
british business
would really rather see a cautious and
irreversible approach rather than
a hasty approach that we have to we have
to reverse
should i just uh just adding to that i
think perhaps what
uh people are not always aware of is the
proportion of the population who
are still left even though we have a
brilliant vaccination program rolling
out
there will still be a large proportion
of the population left who could become
infected in the future so we clearly
need to push the vaccination
program right out we have to keep
looking for new variants that's another
important element as to why we need to
wait and check
and we are actually in the uk uh doing
more
genomics than anywhere else in the world
and that's an important
area to look at but keep observing um
and then we need
that time period there's a there's a two
week to illness
and a two week to so that four to five
week assessment period is
absolutely critical to know that the
intervention
that has gone in and the result are
linked not to have multiple
interventions and then be confused at
what we've
actually managed to achieve thanks a lot
to harry cole
the son thank you prime minister a
question for dr harry's um
education unions have said this morning
they can foresee schools reclosing at
some point again
do you foresee that happening and a
question for the prime minister
the world's media is wall-to-wall with
accusations of britain as an unwelcoming
and racist country today
has that damaged this nation and do you
believe that the royal family queen
aside
is racist
i'll start with the the education
question so um the answer short answer
is hopefully not
because our children's education is so
critical which is why at schools
uh the development first we had a
question early on uh just highlighting i
think how young people have been
affected through
through the pandemic so um i would
certainly not want that to happen but i
think we can be very
optimistic going forward we for all of
the reasons i've
said earlier around our vaccination
programmes and
the surveillance that we have in
operation
the testing program in school should
mean that
the likelihood of a case going into the
school
and then numbers of children having to
come out of education to isolate should
be
very significantly reduced now there may
be and i'll just do a
full warning here there may be a very
short period at the start of this
program where everybody gets used to it
and a larger number of children come out
of school and then it will settle down
so i think it's really important that
when observing this
uh people think through the next three
to four weeks uh not the first one to
two
and uh harry on your on your other point
and look
you know i congratulate you on your very
determined attempt to uh
to involve me in in this uh in this
story more than
uh than i've said all already but i
really think that when it comes to
uh matters to do with the royal family
uh the right thing for prime ministers
to say is uh is nothing and nothing is
the thing
uh that i propose uh to say today about
that
about that particular matter thank you
very much let's go to
dominic yeatman of the metro hi thank
you prime minister
uh your education secretary yesterday
promised the biggest shake-up since the
war
uh with longer school days in a
five-term year among the measures
suggested in a bid to help
children catch up on their missed
education when can
parents and teachers expect to see these
plans and
secondly if i may is three pounds fifty
a week extra an appropriate reward
for the nurses who are steering britain
out of this pandemic
uh dominic first of all on on your point
about i'll come to i'll come to the
education
uh recovery plan but on your point about
about
about
nurses i i would stress that
well first of all the gratitude that i
think everybody feels for
uh to towards the nursing profession
and all health and social care workers
one of the most important things that uh
nurses tell me they want to see is
is is more nurses on to help them
on the wards uh to help them cope with
uh the pandemic and everything else and
there are ten thousand more
now this year than there were last year
and that's a that's a good thing
there's also a big increase in
recruitment by the way i think it's up
something like 36 and uh
i understand of course that the whole
sector has been under
massive pressure and that's why we are
investing uh
colossally on top of the
140 billion pounds annually that we give
to the nhs but an extra 62 billion
pounds
to support the nhs and above all to help
boost that
recruitment drive that i think is is
really crucial for
the well-being uh of of nurses
um uh across the country in addition to
the of course to the 12.8 percent
uh pay increase that they got uh the
most recent
uh the most recent run so uh that that's
where we are
dominic on on that and on your on your
uh
excellent question about um the school's
recovery plan
i would echo what uh the secretary of
state for education said
this is this is a a huge moment we have
to recognize that
parents uh up and down the country
teachers who have been coping with
absolutely exceptional circumstances
some pupils have had
differential loss of learning uh they've
for one reason or another they've been
more disadvantaged
by the pandemic than uh than others we
have to make up
that lost learning we have to be very
creative and very direct
in the way that we do it so one of the
things that we're looking at and that
sir kevin collins the education recovery
commissioner
is looking at is is tutoring and
what you can do to make a difference uh
one-on-one
uh with uh with pupils and um that might
apply to
to kids who who have fallen behind or
kids who just need their potential
uh um unleash in all sorts of ways uh
we're also looking
as as as we've said at
uh the whole uh curriculum making sure
that we do as much as we can
to uh give kids the opportunities that
they need so
the the a lot of work is going to be
done on this and as i said i think at
one of these
press conferences recently i think that
uh actually it is our biggest
national uh challenge uh yes we've got
to
defeat the backlog in the nhs in the
courts all the
the all the problems that have have
built up
uh that have silted up as a result of of
covid but i think the biggest challenge
now
is uh remediating the
the the damage done to the education
of of kids and young people in the in
this country i know we can do it
i absolutely know we can do it but it's
going to take a lot of focus and
a lot of a lot of drive and that's why
we've appointed kevin
uh and and his team okay um
sorry jenny was there a question for you
i don't think i do thank you sorry thank
you dominic
um andrew woodcock the independent
good afternoon um dr harris um if i
could ask you first
we're hearing reports of fairly large
numbers of parents failing to
give permission for their children to be
tested when they return to school
what i'd like to ask is are those
children undermining the safety of their
classmates when they're together in the
classroom
should they be kept separate from their
classmates and
prime minister if i may follow some of
my colleagues in uh straying off the
subject with coronavirus for a second
you are currently threatening for the
second time to unilaterally breach
terms of the northern ireland protocol
which um which you negotiated and you
signed as part of your brexit deal
and we hear that you may be planning to
do the same thing with regards to
imports from the eu to mainland britain
you said at the time of the deal it was
a great deal you said that there were no
non-tariff barriers you told
north irish businessmen that they could
throw any customs forms in the bin
and yet yesterday um lord frost your
minister wrote
that at the time of the negotiations
that it was clear that there was
no world in which the eu would eliminate
trade barriers
um isn't it time now for you to come
clean with voters and
and admit that um all of these problems
are not achieving problems
that but they're the trade barriers and
the damage which they cause are part and
parcel of your brexit deal
i'll start with the the school testing
response um
so i think the first important thing to
say is children should always be
allowed to come into school it's their
right to have an education and it's
important for
their long-term health and actually
their future family's health
so that i think is the first point um i
do recognize that for many parents it's
quite an unusual
ask for you know before children go off
to school to do
to do a swab and a test it will take
time i think for families to get used to
that and
one of the reasons that the testing has
been put in in
in a phased way is so that children have
three tests in school
in a supervised way with support so that
they know
what to expect and my experience was
once the child knows what they want to
do actually
as a parent you had less control over it
they actually saw what the benefits were
and were not frightened of it
i know that many of the testing centers
are offering opportunities
for parents and for families to get used
to
the testing or to seek any help and i
think with time i'm sure families will
give their permission
and will adopt it um partly because
actually it's not just for the child and
the school but it's actually for their
families benefit as well if they have
elderly relatives in the family it gives
that whole family assurance as well so
children will never be forced to have a
test they cannot have a test without
the appropriate permission uh but i
think the important thing is for
for parents to ask if they're concerned
about it um and
people will help them understand what
the test is about
thanks very much andrew on your on your
question about the the northern irish
protocol and the
and the the trade and cooperation
agreement with our friends in the in the
eu i think it is a great deal because
uh it enables us not just to have
uh free trade with the eu but also to do
what
uh we wanted to do which is do things
differently where we
i think that might be a good idea and in
the last few
months you've seen the examples of that
whether it's in the in the vaccination
rollout program or in free trade
agreements that we've been able to
to strike or the free ports that we
announced in the in the budget or doing
uh other forms of regulation uh
differently and and i and
i think that is a and it's great to get
those two things working
uh together that's a free trade
agreement plus the ability to do things
uh differently in in our in our own way
and
uh in so far as the there have been
uh teething problems and and and there's
no question that there
have been uh we're fixing those uh now
with some
temporary uh technical uh
things that we're doing to to smooth
flow which i think are very very
sensible
and i'm sure that it can all be uh
ironed out sorted out uh insofar as the
eu
objects to that uh with um with goodwill
and
and with imagination and that's what we
intend uh to bring
uh to it and i'm sure that our friends
will as well so
uh you'll have to forgive me uh andrew
if i'm considerably more
optimistic about uh all that then uh
perhaps the turn of your question
suggests that uh
that you are at the moment but i think
you're going to be pleasantly surprised
uh as as things uh as common sense
begins to to prevail